[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ma première vue on dirait un jouet cette
voiture est pour ça qu on est à 1 2 3 4
5 dedans c'est un jour réalité c'est une
véritable
excessive
les rapides bien qu'il ne fasse que
trois chevaux fiscaux
il développe
trois chevaux est sérieux c'est sa
puissance et le réel
à 7 minutes
on l'appelle meilleur et non si on
trouve ça c'est un nom qui peut si cette
petite voiture peut porter une charge de
400 kg les 400 kilos c'est la charge que
porte le gros mâle dr
une onde
oman air descendant à quelle clientèle
s'adresse-t-elle richesse c'est une
clientèle
darier
elle peut s'adresser à des jeunes de
l'employé
diverses
elle peut s'adresser également
aux cultivateurs ou à toutes personnes
qui l'utilisent à des fins
professionnelles elles notamment ici
elle est en plastique et ce matériau
pratique permet ici justement en
normandie de l'utiliser au bord de la
mer
retrace l'ordre et les gardes et qu'il
risque de peu différent et possédant des
capteurs et facilement des capucins
rapide excessivement tous les éléments
100 m
la 4 e paper la tâche ardue
exactement bien sûr également
les éléments semblaient jouer tous les
éléments le capot les ailes avant les
dernières se démontant le mécano bon il
vous est demandé aussi c'est du
plastique mais alors comme sas cabosses
justement c'est du plastique souple le
c'est du plastique thermoformé
il est teinté dans la masse était
excessivement simple lorsqu'il reçoit
vous
passez y penser
la pièce couche hélène par exemple la
corde reprend sa position initiale
et si vous la rayer il est impossible
aux dépens de l'art y est sauf
oui
voyez quel point tu veux absolument pas
[Musique]